hey everyone
uh thanks for coming to the talk uh i'm
bing waipung from columbia university
uh and i'm very fortunate to present our
paper
here about training over prioritize the
neural network in near linear time
uh this is a joint work with jan brandt
zhang song and
omari winston yeah okay first uh
let's talk about a neural network yeah
the neural network is the most
powerful tool in the past decades
uh it works so well in the practice
in the practice for example in the
imagenet
challenges its performance keeps growing
and becoming stronger over the past 10
years
and at the year of 2015
it finally beats human and achieves a
lower
classification error than human and and
its performance still uh keep growing
over the last
few years and also in the year of 2017
the upper goal appears and it beats the
top
uh gold player of human and it really
surprised the world at
that time uh yeah and also
yeah for now deep learning uh has been
has attracted research from different
communities over the last few years and
but problems
is that we all been popular deep
learning is still
a mystic to to many people it has a
a lot of its own problems uh for example
the robustness
uh and the deep learning is also lack of
explanation
and over and over there's a still a lot
of problems here
uh and uh in this talk
uh our focus is about neural neck
training
and we consider the the problem of speed
up neurological training
uh here's the outline of uh the talk
uh in the first part of the talk i will
first give a very general background
attract introduction
to the neural net and i will also
introduce the motivation
uh behind our topic uh in the second
part of the talk i will introduce a
recent
advance of over parameters in your
network
and i'll also describe the problem set
up of this paper
and finally i will present our result
a near linear time algorithms for
training our primary interests than your
network
okay let's start i i will first give a
general introduction to the neural
network and also the motivation behind
our topic
uh yeah here's a few facts about neural
net
the number four parameters of neural net
could be extremely large
for example there are over 10 million
parameters for resident eighteen and if
the
the depths of the neural life becomes
even larger then
this number could could uh becomes uh
could also become
large uh yeah the second fact is that
uh training in your life work could be
very slow
for example it takes eight days on eight
gpus just for training one single
uh language model called bird
yeah so based on this fact one can see
that
uh it is really a big problem
uh of practical neural network training
and the quick
key question uh we want to ask
is can we speed up neural network
training
uh yeah of course um there's no surprise
that this topic has been
extensively studied over past years
uh there are extensive efforts on this
from
two uh two communities first from
prague practitioners they developed
some heuristic methods but generally
there are two
problems uh the first problem that of
this heuristic
method often lack of theoretical
guarantees
and the second problem that is that uh
this housing method is often not
scalable
uh to be to be more statistic
they can only work for some specific
task but cannot generalize to
all the training tasks there has also
been some
efforts from the theoretical communities
for example there are many many advances
on
optimization literature over the past
decade
but the problem is that uh most of the
risks this advance
uh aim for congratulations uh but as
as far uh as far as uh as people know
neural network uh could be non-complex
and non-smooth
so there's really a gap between the
this advancing optimization theory and
the neural network training
yeah this thing
brings the problem uh
uh as follow so how can we reason about
uh computation time or competition calls
if when we are
not even clear about the entire
optimization landscape
that is well not even clear about
how fast the conversions can happen and
how long it takes
for for us to train the neonatal to
global optimal uh
without some bad understanding also on
this problem
we cannot talk about computing cost
but fortunately there's there were some
recent advance from
a machine learning community as well as
serato computer science community
and they uh they provide a firm
uh progress on this problem and
accumulating into the following result
which has been proved uh separately by
two groups
one is that two giant postal sign
in 2019 and the other group is alan zhu
uh
lee and sung also in 2019
so their speaking their results they
just follow
so when so suppose the waste of the
neural network
is sufficiently large then one can show
that the stochastic gradient descent
organism
can provely converge to global outmode
and the training laws
will converge to zero
yeah uh
i will then move on to
give some basic uh description
of the neural network and the problem
set up in this paper
uh follow the convention of deep
learning theory uh
we will consider one hidden layer neural
network
um this is a producing uh simplification
of the real neural net uh we will use
xi yi to denote the training data and
we assume uh the input feature xi less
than
uh d dimensional and the output label y
it just comes from minus one one
uh yeah since we can just consider a two
layer
uh neural network uh from yeah
from the right picture one can see the
output prediction of the known like
y just equal to a transpose times y
uh of the w times x where x is the
important feature
uh w is the width matrix of the first
layer y is the activation function
and in this uh paper we take
the relu active efficient function and a
is the weight of the second layer
uh yes just for notation we will
use n to denote the number of training
data we will use im to denote the width
of the neural network that that is the
number of neuron in the first layer
and we will use d to know the input
dimension
okay uh so what's over prime trans on
your network
okay the the the key uh assumption of
all parameters and neural network
is that we assume the ways of the neural
network
it's much larger than the number of
input data
actually we assume m is is greater than
some polynomial factor of this
number of input data and
okay after i introduced our parameter a
neural network i will just leave
some very brief comments on this line of
work
and before moving on to our results okay
so this over parameters neural network
provides a framework for reading about
convergence generalizations
and also robustness and actual uh and
and yeah uh this is a really
decent progress on people in this theory
but for for those who are not very
familiar with
this uh i have to say that uh this is
still very far from the end of the story
uh okay now i will
i'm going to present uh our result
the main result of this paper is
that we design a near linear time
training algorithms for over private
trans and neural network
uh okay our result is presented in this
chart
um there have been a lot of study
uh on the the running time the number of
tuition the cost of presentations
about the training over parameters and
neural network
and this includes the first order method
like greeting descent and adaptive
reading descent
also second order method like natural
gradient descent
and batch natural gradient descent uh
but one can see
from this chart uh like all previous
work
have overall computation cost at least
admin square
so so our our major contribution in this
paper is to
when we design the algorithms that uh
only have a linear dependence
uh on mn of course per division and the
number of diffusion is generally log one
or epsilon
so the overall uh running time of
algorithm is
is just linear in m times and which is
essentially the best we can hope for for
one hidden layer neural network
okay uh i will then briefly describe the
main techniques
we use in our paper uh yeah so briefly
speaking
uh with our techniques mainly falls into
two parts
one is like we use approximate newton
method
instead of the exact newton method
and the second technique we used in our
paper
is that we do some creation of
pre-conditioning
uh we are sketching okay
uh so okay the the key step in newton's
step uh the
newton method is is to perform the
following update
on the weight matrix at each situation
uh that's in
introduction we'll update the the weight
matrix
with the jacobian matrix uh
which is further pre-conditioned
preconditioned by this uh
the inverse of j times j transpose uh
yeah so
so roughly speaking here uh w is the
width matrix f
is the prediction and the j is the
jacobi matrix
and it has dimension of n by
m so what one can easily see
from uh from the above uh expression
uh the main computation culture actually
comes from just the computing j times c
transpose
which already takes admin squares yeah
and
our major techniques uh is to reduce
this mn square
to mn uh yeah so so
our first key observation is that
instead of exactly compute j times c
transpose
we can actually just approximate the j
times j transpose
and derive a proximal version of this
matrix
and then and and and we call this
approximate newton method
and we prove that actually approximation
method
also works as long as the arrow is not
very large
okay uh yes so since the main cause
comes from
computing j times j transpose and we can
uh
where we can just compute the
approximate version of this j times
three transpose
uh what may think of like uh uh we can
approximate just using
the like the faster jl transformation uh
yeah but
actually the key problem here
is that the condition number uh probably
matters in in our problem
so if we just apply a fast jl to
this j times g transpose then
we will incur a very huge huge additive
dependence on and
which is that in bolstering and practice
so
so instead of directly use both jl uh
in our problem we we we further divide
the inner loop proper into first step
into two steps
in the first step we solve a regression
problem and
in the second step we use the result of
regression
problem to update the weight and one can
see the computation cost
mainly comes from the first step that's
solving this
regression problem but fortunately
we can solve we can derive approximate
solution to this
regression problem uh by using
subspacing batting
to facilitate the preconditionally and
then after
perform con preconditioning we can just
perform
we can just conduct gradient descent and
then find a very
uh good uh parking solution to
discretion problem
and finally uh uh
the the the this would means the the
total computation cost the per iteration
is uh linear in m times n and
we also prove that the approximate
newton method
uh has a linear convergence rate
so the total number equation is log one
or epsilon and this is
the total communication just linear
yaman which is essentially the best we
can hope
for this two layer neural net and
finally
uh i would remark that our techniques
also have
applications on some traditional of my
contact summarization problem
and we can also accelerate some
traditional contacts on imagination
problems there
okay uh at the end of this talk i will
uh point out uh several future
directions that
uh that is very interesting to pursue
uh okay the first major uh future
directions
is about overprimitized neural network
uh and the the first concrete future
uh uh the first the first concrete open
question
uh in this field is is that
well with rather we can reduce the
requirement on which m
so as as one can see from the previous
chart
all the resulting over parameters in
neural network
uh it the ways m has
some very large dependence on n and for
example the current of s
result so is that is that we need m to
be greater than to the force
so it's a really interesting question if
we can uh
reduce this depend this dependence
and the the second the interesting
future direction is to
extend our outcome to multiple uh layer
neural network
uh okay i need to remark our our outcome
have some simple attention to
multi-layer neural network and we can
also achieve something
uh achieve some thing like
m square times n uh
but but it can also be achieved by some
other like maybe simple chick like
cancer sketch i guess uh yeah but i
but anyway the the the the interesting
question here is that can matrix over
prime
market layer over parameters neural
network in little o of m
square and and i think uh this is an
interesting question
okay uh the the the second major uh
future direction which i think maybe is
even more interesting in the first part
is that how how can we utilize
randomized linear algebra
in neural network training so in
just in the last two years there has
been some
some dimension with that the there have
been some
papers uh done by some practitioners
that use
already used dimension redux techniques
to uh
to facilitate neurological training and
this technique has already been applied
in practice
for example some some people use like
locality sensitive hashing and also
uh some fast gl transformation to reduce
the computation cost
in a language in the training of a
language model called transformer
uh so yeah so here the question is can
we do more can we apply
some more advanced of randomized linear
algebra to neural language training
and the second future direction uh
i i want to say that uh so so can we
also import linear algebra with some
theoretical guarantees
so in our paper provides the first
attempt to impose
linear algebra to neurological training
with approvals or
the regular guarantees but uh
yeah but the question is can we do more
and and
maybe as more intriguing questions that
can we uh
can we go beyond the over parameters the
neural network framework
and then design some very efficient
algorithms
for for practical neural net okay uh
that's all
thanks
you